هذا حقًا يوم رمزي لسوريا
لأنه يمثل
إعادة ارتباط البلاد مع جيرانها ليس فقط
لأنك تعيد فتح معبر حدودي بين
الأردن وسوريا ولكن يتم إعادة فتح
المعبر الحركي هنا في مرتفعات الجولان
ومن
خلال هؤلاء الأصدقاء فقط من خلال شفرة الحلاقة
الأسلاك الشائكة عبر هذا الحقل ،
يمكنك رؤية العلم السوري يرفرف في
مهب الريح ، وفي الصيف الماضي فقط
لم يكن هذا العلم موجودًا ، حيث كان هناك
قتال عنيف بين قوات المتمردين
وقوات النظام السوري حقًا
ومن أين نحن  على بعد مئات
الأمتار ، كانت هناك قصف مدفعي
رأيناه يصيب الأرض ويصيب
المتمردين ، لكن النظام السوري الآن يسيطر بشكل
كامل على هذا المعبر رغم
أنه ليس مثل المعابر الأخرى ،
وذلك لأن سوريا وإسرائيل ليس لديهما
علاقات دبلوماسية رسمية تديرها الأمم المتحدة
هذا المعبر الحدودي يراقبون هذه
الحدود وما كانت إسرائيل ذات يوم ليس
فقط للعودة إلى الوضع الراهن والهدوء
الذي جاء بعد 1.  974 اتفاقية لكنهم
يريدون أيضًا من الأمم المتحدة التأكد
من إبعاد الجماعات المختلفة التي دعمت النظام السوري مثل حزب الله والقوات الإيرانية عن هذه
الحدود ، لذا فإن الوضع الراهن الذي كان سائداً
في مرتفعات الجولان منذ
عقود
يعود إيان لي سي إن إن.  مرتفعات الجولان